And like now is our moment. It is the Democratic Tea Party moment.
The people whose ideology at its base is about exchanging ideas
and figuring out how best to serve a collective population with
differing opinions are trying to cut one group out of that conversation.
Your limp approach to politics where you half agree with psychotic
fascist imperialist terrorists is never going to work. It's never
going to win and it's immoral. Whoever the [__] gets
through the primary, not only will I vote for them, I will crawl
over broken glass to vote for them.
We're going to move to first story of the day, the Cenk Uygur
video, the
total defeat of Third Way, the Third Way the original Third Way
memo that went out, okay? The Third Way article that went out,
the hit piece on Hasan, the hey, we have to cut these people
out of the coalition cuz they're anti-Semitic,
right? All of that stuff totally defeated. And what did Kyle
call his video? His His video is called complete and total Hasan
victory.
Uh,
complete and total Hasan victory.
Uh-oh. There's a massive war civil war going on when it comes
to MAGA, specifically among the the pundits. The base is still
with Trump, but the right-wing pundits are at war with each other.
But what fewer people know is that there's also currently a Democratic
civil war going on. And in that Democratic civil war, you have
Third Way, which is a literal like corporate organization.
Uh, they are going after Hasan [__] and by extension
everybody on the left flank of the Democratic Party, okay? And
what they've done is they've is obviously true. This is obviously
true. Yep. Smeared Hasan viciously and relentlessly. They've
called him an anti-Semite, which he's not. That's absurd to call
him that. They say, you know, he's not a team player. They compare
him to Nick Fuentes and say that this guy is just as extreme
as Nick Fuentes. And what they're trying to do is cancel the
entire left flank of the political spectrum and say, you can't
take these people seriously.
Dude, you Have you guys ever heard the thing where people try
to say
There's like a joke. I know John Mulaney had this joke. Other
stand-ups had the same joke. It's I don't know where it comes
from, but it's like
Uh, I think the John Mulaney example is with the word [__]
and somebody at one of his jobs says, you can't say [__]
That's the N- for little people.
And John Mulaney goes, no, it's not. Why would you compare it
to the N- You can't You can't say
You can't not say the N- and say [__] in the same
sentence and then go, but they're equal. They're the same, right?
And there's something very similar happening with Hasan and Nick
Fuentes where people will say, Hasan and Nick Fuentes are the
same. And I'm like, okay. Well, you just You just talked about
and read all of Hasan's worst quotes uncensored.
I'm going to send you a top 10 list of Nick Fuentes quotes uncensored.
I want you to read them to your audience. CNN Jake Tapper, I
want you to make eye contact with that camera. I'm going to throw
up the 10 worst Nick Fuentes quotes on the teleprompter. You
read them and then you tell your audience, this is just like
Hasan [__] in those quotes I read before.
I If he could do that, I'll literally I'll literally go back
to doing anti-Hasan propaganda all the time immediately. I'll
jump off of I'll jump off of the, you know, Hasan's one probably
not one of the five worst human beings in America. I'll jump
off that train and I'll just do, hey, let's Let's Let's get Hasan.
Let's Let's destroy Hasan again.
I'll switch immediately.
What do you mean best? I don't mean best. I mean like literally
the most
I'm not going to say I mean best. That That's just farming. Lazy
farming. Nah. Nah. Nah. Anyway, so the the comparison of the
two is just goofy. And it's not even to say that Nick is evil
or something. I'm not even trying to argue that Nick is evil.
I'm saying that comparing the two of them and saying that they're
the same in terms of their anti-Semitism
is just foundationally wrong, fundamentally misleading, not true,
completely untrue. And everybody who tries to argue that is obviously
a disingenuous hack.
Then you. The Democratic Party needs to be a right-leaning party.
They need to be a centrist party. Um, and they need to represent
the interests of the Israel lobby and corporations. That's the
fight that's going on. And they thought that by canceling Hasan
[__] and uh, you know, quoting him out of context
and running his worst moments, they thought they'd be able to
to shut this guy out completely. In reality, the exact opposite
has
Okay? In reality, uh, now more people are Googling him than ever
before and people are tuning in to his channel to see, well,
what's this guy really about? And what they find out very quickly
is, oh my god, he's been viciously lied to and viciously smeared.
And so, uh, this backfired colossally. Now, having said that,
we also now, uh, have hit the peak here because the king of the
liberals himself,
uh, who Ezra Klein
Dude, I think it's so funny.
So, when you pull up like the trending thread that Kyle's going
to work off of, It's very funny because
Hasan Hasan wanted to use this one with the picture. I wanted
to highlight in as big of terms as I could, Ezra Klein wrote
this opinion. Cuz that is the big deal about this, right? It's
that Ezra Klein wrote it. Not that anyone else wrote it. It's
that Ezra Klein wrote it. Now, Ezra Klein would naturally believe
this, but the problem is So, Ezra Klein basically argues there
shouldn't be purity testing. It should be a big tent and you
don't focus on the the downsides of the other people,
what what that means or what what that's worked out to is a whole
bunch of people saying, oh yeah, we need to follow Ezra Klein's
like abundance attitude towards like we want abundance Democrats.
We want a big tent. We need to move towards like moderation.
We need to moderate, get those moderates in here. And then the
second somebody looks left like somebody like Hutch. This is
what Hutch has done. Hutch thinks Ezra Klein is like Jesus Christ.
Hutch has been arguing for all of Ezra since abundance came out
for this I don't know, past 12 months or something,
despite this, he was still extremely adamant about purity testing
out Hasan. I don't understand that. So, when I say like 9/11
for abundocrats, it's really like the the Hutch type of abundocrats
who want to embrace a bunch of the things that these people are
arguing for, the Third Way types or the the centrist centrist
libs lib types. They want to take part of it, apply it
and then still say, no, we should cut this guy out.
It's very goofy, right? It's not a big deal that it's his take.
No, it is a big deal that it's his take because a bunch of people
actually try to say that this guy is like somebody they they
understand, they follow, that they're like following what he's
put out in the world, and then they don't actually do that. So,
it is a big deal that it's him as well. It's also a big deal
that he felt the need to write it. Yes. That's true. Now, this
is a response in the in the thread. Anyway, we keep watching.
But I just thought it was funny. Kyle's talking about the king
liberal king of the liberals. >> Because the king of the
liberals
uh, who Ezra Klein, he is now out here defending Hasan in no
uncertain terms. So, he writes an article. The original title
of the article in the New York Times is Hasan [__]
is not the enemy. Oh my
Oh my The Israel lobby is seething. Third Way is seething. The
diet MAGA Democrats are seething at this. Now, in this he goes,
you know, basically, uh, comment for
Kyle Kyle is so psyched about this. I guarantee you somebody's
going to watch this Kyle video and go, why are you mad that Democrats
are mad? Why are you mad that our allies in the coalition are
mad? Why are you mad Or sorry, why are you happy that we're mad
and Israel's mad? Why are you happy about this? I thought we
were allies. These people don't These people hate us.
That's I guarantee you that's going to be a response from some
people. Total losers, but all the ones that people say are the
worst Hasan [__] comments. Um, and and he breaks
them down and
look, I disagree with this one in this way, but this one is out
of context and they're smearing him for this reason and that
reason. And um, he even, you know, swats away the most pervasive
lie nefarious lie about Hasan that he's somehow an anti-Semite
because he criticizes Israel, because he criticizes the genocide,
and because he's anti-Zionist, because he's against ethno-states
and he's for secular democracies. Right? So, anti-Zionism is
rising as a response to what Israel is doing. It will simply
not be possible to treat it as a marginal viewpoint that can
be shamed or shunned.
LET'S GO!
He Dude, Kyle Kyle and I are of one mind, okay? Let's go. Kyle
Kulinski and me the bridge is real. The bridge is real and it's
it's here. We're here for it. Let's
into invincibility or invisibility, I should say. Yes, anti-Semitism
often cloaks itself in anti-Zionism.
So, don't do the anti-Semites' work for them. If you keep telling
people that if they oppose the Jewish state, then they must hate
Jewish people, eventually they will believe you, says Ezra Klein.
He also says this, but to only focus on those comments Oh [__]
Oh [__] Oh my god, he's also retweeting Substance.
Oh my god. Sorry, he's also Substance made the video. It's a
test. It's a test. It's a test.
It could It could work. It could be a thing. It's possible.
I'm not going to I'm not going to Who says no?
Who says Who says no? Dude, let's let's go. Let's go.
You. Awesome. Says Ezra Klein. He also says this, but to only
focus on those comments is to miss to miss much else that [__]
has said and believes. He has also said, from pogroms to the
Holocaust have always been singled out by those in power as a
scapegoat for the instability and economic volatility that people
in power caused. A resilient nation anti-Semitism is a constant
threat. He has called anti-Semitism gross, immoral, and a hate
crime. He has promoted Jon Ossoff, a Democratic senator from
Georgia, who is as a 2028 presidential possibility. In previous
presidential primaries, Uygur has supported Bernie Sanders, who
is
It is an unusual form of hatred that calls out anti- Semitism
and promotes Americans for the presidency. God damn, son. So,
this is a complete and total not only Hasan [__]
victory, but it is by proxy a victory for the entire left flank.
They tried to cancel the entire left flank of the Democratic
Party here and failed miserably.
Which Yeah, like it's a it's a victory in that it it's just particularly
embarrassing. The people whose ideology at its base is about
exchanging ideas and figuring out how best to serve a collective
population with differing opinions are trying to cut one group
out of that conversation.
Like they are acting anti-liberal by trying to purity test these
people out, right? And it's it's kind of funny at
there's a little bit revealed here in like how close this might
have come to working or how concerned people might have been
because realistically this just gets you like into the tent to
have the conversation.
This doesn't win you any election. This doesn't really do anything.
It just gets you like into the tent to have the conversation
in the first place. Like so you can actually talk about your
ideas. So, you can have you know, you can talk to the politicians.
You can maybe go to the DNC and interview politicians and say,
"Hey, this is what I want from the people who are serving
So, it's very interesting that
you know, people say they're serving liberal democracy by cutting
these people out. I don't I don't know about
Anyway, I'm sure somebody is writing a DM or a email to me right
now sending me some Karl Popper quotes. We'll see. Cuz we are
rising. It is our turn to take the reins of power. It is our
turn to fight back against the fascists and show the corporate
centrists how it's done. Your limp dick approach to politics
where you half agree with psychotic fascist imperialist terrorists
is never going to work. It's never going to win and it's immoral.
We need actual lefties. We need the opposite of MAGA. And now
we're going to teach you a lesson lesson and we're going to show
you how this thing goes, okay? Hasan also went on another place
which I think it's fair to call I'm going to be real I love Kyle.
I love the energy.
That's probably not necessarily true like you literally you just
got you just paid like the the entry fee to get in here, okay?
That's all that you you paid the entry fee. That's it. Right?
You paid the entry fee to like go and have the conversation.
Now you got to win it. Now you got to be somebody who actually
like campaigns and wins hearts and minds. Which I think, you
know, the left flank of the party is set up to do that. They
got Kyle. They've got Breaking Points. They got a lot of like
media presence.
They're they're set up to do it. They actually have to execute
now though. This this is like yes, now the real actual politicking
starts. Uh the king of the liberals here. Ezra Klein is the king
of the liberals and then I guess you could call Pod Save like
the liberal lion's den or something, right? They did a a long
interview here and they got into it and man, again, the attempt
to cancel Hasan backfired colossally. All of those candidates
who were out there saying, "I wouldn't go on his show. I would
never How dare you?" They now look incredibly immensely out of
touch and stupid. And by the way, the people like Slotkin who
said, "Oh, I I wouldn't go on Hasan's show." She goes on Bill
Maher's show all the time and Bill Maher says actually bigoted
[__] Says genuinely genuinely Islamophobic [__]
Says insane stuff from time to time. By the way, Bill Maher said
about the 9/11 hijackers, "Well, they weren't cowards. Say what
you want about them, but they definitely weren't cowards. They
flew a plane into a building."
If Hasan said that, you Oh, I would never I wouldn't be in the
same room as you. How dare you? But Bill Maher said it and Alyssa
Slotkin brags about going on Bill Maher's show. These people
are dinosaurs. They're completely and utterly out of touch. And
the fact of the matter is they have lefties derangement syndrome.
That's what it is. So, here is Hasan [__] on Crooked
Media here on Pod Save America and listen to this back. So, I
think like it's really weird to me because there seems to be
a pretty big split. Yeah, the the Berniecrats types, the like
working class populism types.
The thing that people always say we cater to progressives on
is the trans
Was Bernie Sanders out here being like, you know, we need 13-year-olds
with trans like we we need like youth gender medicine. I feel
like Bernie was very focused on economic issues and really like
his support for any of the trans stuff seemed more tacit than
than like excitedly. back and forth. >> You said you wouldn't
vote for Gavin Newsom against J.D. Vance in 2028 and you'd vote
third party. >> I mean I don't I don't even think that's
going to be a problem with the but like a lot of people In other
words, what he's saying here is Gavin's going to lose the primary.
He's going to lose the primary cuz he's shooting himself in the
dick. He's shooting himself in the dick by talking to Ben Shapiro
and saying to Ben Shapiro that he doesn't think what Israel did
is a genocide when like 90% of Democrats believe it is a genocide
and are morally outraged by it. He's shooting himself in the
dick by arguing against a billionaire's tax in California right
now as we speak uh when, you know, Democrats are waking up and
realizing class politics is like a a factual truth. Right? I
mean, we just saw the whole Epstein scandal. They're kids on
an island. This is what the top 1% is. This is what the Epstein
class is and Gavin Newsom wants to make sure we don't raise their
taxes. So, this is why it's not going to be a problem cuz Gavin
Newsom is probably not going to hang on and become the winner
because he doesn't have the politics to fit the moment. >> Including
people who who share a lot of your critiques of the Democratic
Party hear that and think like this is the problem, you know,
when the stakes are concrete like a Vance presidency and another
4 years of what we're living through, you know, the people who
say they're building a movement would, you know, like rather
preserve their own power than, you know, do what winning requires
and, you know, hold your nose and vote for what you believe would
be the lesser of two evils. Like how do you respond to that?
I want the Democratic Party to treat me like a never-Trumper.
I want the Democratic Party to treat me like a triple-Trump voter,
okay? Cuz it turns out that's all they're tuned into. So, if
that if what it takes for the Democrats to turn around and be
like, "Wait a minute, we're losing this guy. We Dude, Kyle Kyle's
like actually
He is he's never seen something he likes more than than Hasan
pointing out the weird obsession with winning like the the middle
that it that Democrats have. Like this weird obsession with just
being as moderate as possible, as like disparate in their approach
as possible. Like basically giving tiny little concessions to
every group they can hoping more people vote for them.
and and their obsession with yeah, going and and courting never-Trumpers,
it seems like. Kyle Kyle's never heard something he agrees with
more and Hasan's actually formulating it well. This was one of
the things he formulated well was this like this center pivot
that a lot of Dems are doing and he's like, "Just pretend just
pretend that I'm like thinking about voting for J.D. Vance, right?
Like just think just just, you know, pretend that I'm like thinking
about voting for J.D. Vance. Then come and then come and talk
to me." Very funny, okay? Very funny. >> into. So, if that
if what it takes for the Democrats to turn around and be like,
"Wait a minute, we're losing this guy. We have to win him over
again." or whatever instead of just like taking my vote for granted
as they've done so over and over again for the left flank. Um
and then, you know, I'm going to say things that may or may not
end up uh being true, but it doesn't matter. We're so far out
from the election anyway that it's like I'm I'm just saying,
"Look, now is your opportunity to find a good candidate instead."
But you see But you see as we head into these that like after
what we've lived through these last years, the stakes and the
stark difference between even a Democrat who um you and I might
find uh not up to par to say the least versus Vance or whoever
the [__] they put up. >> Of course. I mean,
I I hate Republicans. I oppose them. I I say that all the time.
I I think that the Republicans are are far more damaging. The
biggest terrorists uh the biggest domestic terrorists in this
country, the biggest terrorists internationally is the Republican
Party. And not only that, but it's just like uh they like I I
I want to fight against the the growing fascist movement in this
country. My frustration with the Democrats is their conciliatory
attitude towards that and and their lack of investment in this
struggle. This this idea that, you know, on the one hand you
say Donald Trump's a dangerous force. I see that. I recognize
that. But then you turn around and you take on his anti-immigrant
narratives and anti- So, there's something to be said for like
the energy you project.
I don't know how many Dems project like an energy of like
Huh, it's I I don't know how to say it. It feels like focus grouped.
That's That's the thing is a lot of the Democrats just feel very
focus grouped. Whenever even when they're outraged about something
or upset about something, they just feel focus grouped and that
comes through. The thing Trump did was not try to win moderates,
right? It was, "Hey, things are broken right now. It's unacceptable
and here's how we have to fix things." And then he said a whole
bunch of Imagine if he came in with that same energy. Things
are totally broken right now and here's how we have to fix things.
Dude, imagine I think you could I honest to God
Aside from, let's say, not the money, the basic universal basic
income. I think you could run with like Andrew
idea of how automation is going to affect America. And if you
just find somebody charismatic charismatic to carry that idea,
you will win elections. You just need somebody who's not like
the least charismatic that's ever
It's It's actually cataclysmic to that message that Andrew Yang
was the guy who went through with it cuz he was like the least
the least Sorry, I clicked on the wrong message. He's like the
least charismatic guy that's ever existed. And so he's the person
who is saying that message all over the place and then people
are like, "Ah, I don't know about that message." It's like, "Dude,
no. It is actually a huge problem. I think that's the the angle
you have to come from is automation, offshoring. These things
are a huge problem. How do we fix that in the American economy?
How do we take advantage of the the actual advantages we have
before we lose them?"
But the problem is that's totally shaking things up. That's that's
totally shaking things up and Dems are still trying to stick
to this current status
And so I do think people on the outside of that have a chance.
I mean it's real and I think if you start investing in that idea
now, the economy, people's general economic well-being is only
getting worse year over year. We are We need a paradigm shift
to start to shift that
If there's no paradigm shift to shift away from it from this
like slow degradation,
then then eventually you're going to get I mean you get one form
of of authoritarianism or another, right? Like things have to
be shaken up and hopefully by people who are good people who
can be torchbearers for those ideologies and aren't going to
be looking to like overthrow democracy
Yeah, we're I
have like slow played it. I haven't really talked about it a
ton. You hear it cuz I'm like consistently blackpilled, but I
do think we're at the time at a time
not unlike the lead-up to like World War or World War where like
the status quo is not working for the average person and people
are willing to just roll the dice on like wildly different ideas,
wildly different things than have been like attempted or
I think broadly the Democratic Party in the US is the last entity,
major political party to be like caught completely unaware by
this.
I think. It It feels that way. Not totally sure. I don't have
sources for that, but that's like that's the feeling I have when
I watch I listen to Kyle I watch politics overall. >> the immigrant
messaging from the 2020 election that you won. By the way, that's
a bar. The Republican Party is the biggest terrorist organization
on the planet. That's a bar. That's also something I've been
saying for a long time. Like you guys know my whole spiel. It's
a fascist terrorist imperialist death cult. That's what the Republican
Party is at this point. So I actually I'm in total agreement
with the the Yeah, I don't know if you thought I was demonizing
automation. That's precisely the the point, Stalinmate.
the point. Yeah.
the like automation is going to happen one way or another. It
is that basically the way the economy set up, automation is slowly
going to take jobs away. Automation is slowly going to Yeah,
take jobs and even continue offshoring will take jobs. And if
there's no way to maintain the the lifestyle or the the general
living standards of the American populace, well, the American
populace still still controls the
Sorry, the American populace still controls the American military
to some extent. That's the other thing when I start to think
about why this Iran war was undertaken, it starts to feel like
to deplete the American military as much as possible.
Anyway, that's Hey, we're not going to talk about that. Let's
keep going. and and liberals when they say like listen, it sorry,
when push comes to shove, whoever the [__] gets through
the primary, not only will I vote for them, I will crawl over
broken glass to vote for them. Without a doubt, okay? So like
that's going to happen regardless.
Having said
Hold on. Was that a blue no matter who commitment from Kyle?
Actually, I'm in total agreement with the the Democrats and and
the liberals when they say like listen, it sorry, when push comes
to shove, whoever the [__] gets through the primary,
not only will I vote for them, I will crawl over broken glass
to vote for them. Without a
That's Kyle on the record blue no matter who, okay? Blue no matter
who. But now here's the very funny thing, okay? Here's the very
funny thing. Flip that on its head. Will you get that same commitment
for 2028
from the liberal types, from the
Will you get that same commitment?
Do you really believe so? Do you really Do you really believe
so?
That you'll get that same commitment. Hey, Grand Platter, if
he's the candidate in Maine, 2026 even. Grand Platter, if he's
the candidate in Maine, are you all out there? Are you all out
there canvassing for him? Are you going to Cuz I still see a
lot of liberals by the way, knowing that platform is Sorry, knowing
that Platter is winning, I see a ton of liberals on Twitter taking
shots at him constantly.
It's liberals and Republicans both beating up on Grand Platter
trying to get his numbers down so they could get Janet Mills
in there, okay? It's pretty crazy.
It's like okay, but if he wins, if he wins, do I have a commitment
from Not not just Listen, cuz hey,
I'm just We watched that that panel when when Soy Boy points
out the Progressive Victory did support those candidates, right?
We watched the panel and they went, well, they said she's good
enough. That's not really an endorse
Third Way will attack Platter as well, maybe. Okay. So like that's
going to happen regardless.
Having said that, we can do better than Newsom. We can do better
than people who are constantly themselves to MAGA and the Republicans,
okay? That's the part that people need to realize that part of
politics is throwing around your weight and saying, listen, I
want to support you, but here here's what I want. Here's what
I want. There's a clip of Kamala Harris talking about how we
need to be more transactional in our politics. Don't be afraid
to speak up and say, you want my vote, here's what I want from
you. I I I'm not asking. I am demanding you end the illegal and
offensive war against Iran. I'm demanding that you do that, okay?
Like
this is how politics functions and everybody seems to understand
that unless and until it's a left-winger who's saying, look,
we're years out from the election, but I'm just telling you right
now, this is the path I want you to take and this is the path
to victory. Somehow it's a scandal whenever somebody on the left
says it. And by the way, all of the polling data backs up what
the lefties always say. Like hey,
Okay, the polling data now backs up the liberal stuff, okay?
Sorry, the Israel
I don't think I think that's more The lefties tend to have the
right idea. It's like the technology adoption curve, okay? The
lefties tend to have the right idea early, but there's some of
the early adopters who who sometimes just get like way out over
their skis before the public's ready to hear stuff and start
saying like crazy [__] So if he says like as we always
told you, the the public polling is with, you know, Palestinians
over Israel. If he says that right now, I might go I might have
to have a laugh, okay? Cuz it really is a very recent phenomenon
where this has changed over. I do think that it was I think if
you were informed on the issue, it did seem like it was obviously
going to go that way, but a lot of people weren't informed. We
can get into why that is, but a lot of people weren't informed
and it's just now starting to switch. Ideal Democratic candidate
would want Medicare for all. They'd want a living wage. They'd
want free college. They'd want universal child care. They'd want
to raise taxes on the wealthy, they'd want to end the wars, okay?
They'd want to or Um TBK 911.
So TBK 911, you could say this.
Uh foreign policy is still really low on voters listed priorities.
Unfortunately,
might be the case, but specifically with regards to Israel, that
will no longer be the case because what's number one on voters
priority list every single time? It's the economy, stupid.
And guess what foreign policy has done? Guess what American foreign
policy has done? It's nuked the global economy.
Like understandably, obviously, in a transparent way that is
obvious even to the dumbest individuals in America, the dumbest
individuals in America will know that this war affected foreign
policy and so the people's position on Israel will actually be
relevant because it is the economy, stupid.
You know what I'm saying? So I'm not calling you stupid. I'm
saying it's the economy, stupid is something people say about
politics. It's always the number one issue and now it is actually
like foreign policy has nuked the the economy. And trust me,
even if they open the streets today, if all the mines were gone
today, stuff is still really Stuff is still going to get a lot
more expensive. Yeah. So that is how it is.
Yeah, I'm sure we I'm sure we even agree on this. I'm just using
your chat message to basically say what I believe again. So don't
don't feel like that was a direct attack on you, okay? You're
You're fine. Thank you for being here. Arrest the Trump regime
thugs and criminals. Arrest the Epstein class
Dude, arrest is not enough for the Trump
Arrest is absolutely not enough for the Trump people. Uh and
and that's not to say um So So that's not to even say that I
want them like executed or something. That's not what I'm talking
about. The property they gained as a result of their illicit
behavior needs to be taken.
Any increase in wealth that came as a result of any backroom
deals that they were doing needs to be taken from them. They
cannot keep the wealth, they cannot keep their ill-gotten gains
and I think that's I think you
Like this is the one place where I'd say break away from liberalism
and I I like I actually don't care. Risk taking more away. Risk
taking more away now because anything that they've gotten from
doing this Holy [__]
It needs to be clear. It needs to be
And maybe this is something the founders should have thought
about, but it needs to be clear that if people start using the
government to enrich themselves in a way that is totally transparent
and obvious to everybody, those people need to be punished in
the harshest terms
And it needs to be clear like, hey, I get it. Sometimes you guys
do like a wink wink handshake deal and somebody gets like a cushy
consulting job after they leave the presidency or after they
leave the Senate or something. Okay, I'm not saying we like take
everybody's property who does that. I don't like it, but at least
there's like some amount of Okay, this is like some There's only
so much
corruption you can get out of the system, okay?
There's only so much. And so you don't want I I don't even need
to say that we we end that because that honestly is something
you can you can reasonably expect would be in any system. Even
authoritarian systems, that level of corruption will exist. So,
I don't I'm not trying to go after that stuff right now, although
I think it's
I'm saying there is something that is like two to three orders
of magnitude worse happening than that. And that stuff needs
to be met and analyzed and and handled in a vacuum.
Sorry, the uh Digiviking. I think I was I was reading your message
originally. What's your convictions? I watch you now and again
on my TV. Would love to hear you talk about policy. What's your
Um probably more of like a a populist or social leaning economically.
I used to say I was conservative socially, but realistically
like the social policy of most
most of the left-leaning parties in the civilized world is basically
where I'm at now. It got a little too over its skis in COVID.
But realistically like at this point, I think we're about in
the right place.
Like I I think youth gender medicine was something where I'm
like, this is too far. This is I I think this is proceeding without
sufficient research. This seems like way too far. I think it's
putting people off. And that's not to say trans people shouldn't
have rights. It's just like specifically the youth gender medicine
stuff seemed to be getting pushed a little too quickly.
That was one of the lines of along which I said I was socially
conservative.
not that socially conservative beyond that. Except I I do think
there's there's some stuff like societally that I think just
in terms of you know, lack of meaning for people
that I think needs to be fixed, but I don't know if that's social
conservatism or just general
consciousness. Like just being having like some concern about
people, you know, feeling alienated.
They don't feel anything.
Oh boy. Chase Doc is drifting further and further to tankieism.
In what way? I still I still think like open markets are good.
I think a lot of so like services, a lot of government services
can be socialized. A a lot of things can be the public private
partnership is probably a little overstated
in how effective it is. This is like basic [__] right?
And we're allowed to have our preferences. We're allowed to voice
our opinions. We're allowed to say, "Hey, that Democrat is way
too cozy with MAGA and far too right-wing and far too corporate."
You need to be allowed TO SAY ESPECIALLY YEARS OUT FROM a election.
Yes, if it's the day before the election, everybody should be
like I said, I crawl over broken glass to vote for any Democrat
against this terrorist organization that we call the Republican
Party. But like there's a time and place for a primary and for
a fight and to pick who's going to be the standard-bearer. And
the point that Hasan is making is, "Hey, you like the Clintonites,
you've had your chance like multiple times over, [__]
Right? And what happened? You kept
And so, instead of shunning and disrespecting and spitting the
eye of the left, maybe you should learn from the left. Especially
when you have right-wingers and like MAGA people who are saying
openly, "Oh, I would never vote for a Democrat under any circumstances
whatsoever." Okay, then why are you bending over backwards to
try to please them when you should be trying to please people
like Hasan who are telling you, "Look, I want to vote for you."
The Democratic Party, by the way, like totally agree, would vote
for Dems if I was in America. I literally flipped my vote because
of how Trump was talking um before the Canadian election, the
last Canadian election. I flipped my vote. I was voting I was
going to vote conservative. I was. I flipped my vote. I voted
Liberal because I thought one, I live in a place that was obviously
going to vote conservative. But so, not much I could do, okay?
Unfortunately.
But I thought it was important to signal
I'm going to vote Liberal because I don't want
somebody in government for Canada. I don't want a leader in government
for Canada that would vote or sorry, that would even remotely
agree with Donald Trump. Like this guy is such a cancer on the
planet that I'm switching up I'm I'm I'm voting Liberal. I'm
I'm voting LPC.
I think the the problem with the Democrats to me is is still
the the big tent coalition for one thing, having no message.
I understand you want to be the party of like liberal values.
I get it.
But it does feel rough to me and and there is this intractable
problem you get when you want to form a big tent coalition and
represent a bunch of different values, you start to lose and
water lose your message and water it down and it's difficult
to say what you stand for.
You have a lot of different a lot of different people in that
big tent who have totally conflicting worldviews, totally conflicting
ideas of how the country should be run.
And so, that is the that is the challenge when you go into all
this. And I I do think
I do think the the Occupy Wall Street energy, all that stuff.
I know it's it's like cringe to always bring it back to But it
does feel like that's the way forward. It does feel like that's
the only way forward.
And I know that that involves like embracing a little bit of
populism, but it does feel that it's not just like it's not just
populist. It's also like logical in my opinion. Given the transfer
that's happening that has been happening since the Occupy Wall
Street stuff was being talked about. Like that wealth transfer
has not reversed in any way. And everybody's starting to get
it. I watched the All-In podcast, right? That's the one with
all the billionaires. And I think it's I think it's Jeff Sachs
who ends up saying like, "Dude, if we don't find a way to like
help Americans earn money, like they're going to they're going
to like cut our heads
Like unironically, that's like a billionaire saying like, "Guys,
we have to figure out how to help people like get some of this
wealth that we're all getting or they're going to cut our heads
off." Like you have to understand this. And it's like, "Yeah,
like nobody wants to cut heads off."
And like I don't think he was really joking to be clear. And
I do think that's why those billionaires are buying all those
bunkers, to be fair. But to some extent, it's like just a slow
transfer back, like a slow
I I don't know if it involves balancing everything around the
stock market. I don't know how you do it economically. But the
idea the core idea is
that the average person is going to be less and less capable
of earning a
wage and and supporting themselves. That is going to continue.
Time that as time marches on, that will get worse. The average
person is who votes. If if you're basically signing up to say,
"Okay, well, we're going to keep making your life worse until
things explode." I don't know what to tell you. So, something
has to happen, right?
And it it actually is getting to the point where I think we've
gone past the point of like incrementalism necessarily where
it's just like liberals solving the current problem with liberal
means. And we've started to reach the point where it's like we're
looking at more of a paradigm shift, like a soft non-violent
revolution of sorts. That's what you have to be looking at now.
I think that's where the the window is moving to.
I don't think we're at the point where and we're probably quite
far away from the point where violent revolution is is
But it does seem like a sort of like a Is it they call it a color
Is that what a color revolution is? Like a a sort of revolution
within one system that is non-violent. But I think that's more
to do with like political
color revolution. What's the What's the definition of color revolution?
Oh, no. I I actually think color revolution is appropriate here.
Color revolutions are a series of often non-violent youth-led
protest movements that occurred in the post-Soviet states. Yeah,
that I think that would possibly like be pretty close to what
I'm talking about. Color revolutions are a bit of a meme. Well,
I I I don't know, but I'm saying that like a non-violent revolution
is probably what you're looking at. Not necessarily revolution.
You might not even have to up like
have upheaval in the electoral system at all. Right? Like you
might be able to do this through electing politicians still.
But it will be politicians operating on radically different platforms,
I think.
I think. Congrats on making it on Kyle. I was happy when I saw
it. Yeah, we're watching the video right now. Color revolution
is induced by an outside power usually. Oh, I didn't think so.
I didn't think that was a what a color revolution was, but okay.
I don't Listen, I don't think that's what's happening. I think
there's real pain from people.
I think real pain that needs to actually
addressed in some way. And like MAGA people who are saying openly,
"Oh, I would never vote for a Democrat under any circumstances
whatsoever." Okay, then why are you bending over backwards to
try to please them when you should be trying to please people
like Hasan who are telling you, "Look, I want to vote for you.
Here's Here are my conditions, right?" So, um I mean, it's just
it's it's flawless victory for the left, flawless victory for
Hasan. And if you go and you read the comment section of the
New York Times piece that Ezra Klein wrote and read the comment
section of the Pod Save America the podcast, you'll find out
very quickly, it's over. It's over. We won. The left has won
the Democratic Civil War. There is no coming back for the corporate
centrist diet MAGA hacks. You're too cozy with the right. You're
too cozy with power. You're too cozy with big money. And like
now is our moment. It is the Democratic Tea Party moment. And
so, uh Mm, do I agree with this? I don't know if I agree with
this. I I get the energy.
It's like there's this split right now in terms of what to do.
Like let's say let's say you feel like you won as the left wing
of the party right now, which I don't think you should think
that. Like what to do with the people who have been consistently
lobbying against you and have been consistently like misconstruing
you and trying to put you up as like some big scary force. Let's
say you had one. I'm not I'm not even totally sure, okay?
But let's say let's say you had one.
I'm not sure that getting rid of those voices getting rid of
those people is necessarily like the good thing to do. That'll
be something I have to think about. Is like cuz this is the idea
of like, "Oh, if you've been advocating for Israel, you shouldn't
have a place in politics anymore." I don't know if I believe
in that.
I don't think I believe in that. And he's saying that right now.
Like that's essentially what he's saying.
And I man, it's tough.
It's tough to say. You'll find out very quickly, it's over. It's
over. We won. The left has won the Democratic Civil War. There
is no coming back for the corporate centrist diet mega hacks.
You're too cozy with the right. You're too cozy with power. You're
too cozy with big money. And like now is our moment. It is the
Democratic Tea Party moment. And so Okay. I see. So, hold on.
I'm thinking about this same concept now listening to that again.
There's probably the thing you things you'd have to weigh are
basically like if you are
if you do think this is your moment and you can attack these
people like the more, you know, never Trump types. Like I'm not
going to use the bull worker as an example. Probably some people
in the bull worker. Although some people in the bull worker would
be fine as well. Tim Miller seems pretty open to most ideas.
And I think the idea is basically like you've won a battle and
you say you've won, but now with your advantage are you going
to continue to like denigrate your opponent? Like degrade your
opponent.
Right? If you see the more liberal type you even not even the
liberal types, but let's say the
the very pro-Israel
very pro-corporation
Democrats. Do you continue to degrade them so that they are less
of a threat over time? Do you take this opportunity to degrade
them knowing that possibly if you degrade them enough that if
the if the right wing runs like a a J.D. Vance or let's say a
Marco Rubio that they might be immediately back over there.
I mean I think I think a lot of those people are only there right
now because it's Trump. If it was anybody but Trump including
who had all the same rhetoric of as Trump but just wasn't Trump
literally I think all of those people would be back. Right? Like
if J.D. Vance runs again, I think Sarah Longwell and a whole
bunch of other people would end up back in that party. I really
do.
And despite J.D. Vance having no respect for a liberal democracy
whatsoever and have has said so, maybe J.D. Vance might be aligned
though. Possibly not J.D. Vance, but anybody past J.D. Vance
obviously Marco Rubio. I think she said as much that she would
vote for Marco
I think that's where she's just back in that party. And I think
a lot of people are. Connor, some a lot of these other people,
right? I think they're immediately back over there. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. So
I get what Kyle is saying is is you want to take this opportunity
to degrade your opponent's ability to to exert influence in your
party. That makes some sense. I think
I think broadly as
you know, after we do 2026, after we do the midterms, I think
broadly you're going to see those people start to shrink away
anyway. I think they're going to realize that a lot of their
their ideas aren't going to be successful.
And I see I see Kyle's point now. I see what he's talking about.
Cuz realistically it's about the wealth
And when you see Sarah Longwell taking money from the Koch brothers
from like 501c3s who operate on their behalf it's
do you think she's invested in the wealth disparity getting smaller?
Do you think she's at all invested in that? Do you think she
gives a [__] about that?
I mean she obviously doesn't. I think that's like literally about
a part of her values would be if you're going to positively frame
it, she doesn't think there should be handouts. She thinks people
should be able to pull themselves up by their bootstraps. If
they work hard enough, they should be able to earn money. Now
is she ever going to admit the fact that probably we may be we
may be past the point? Right? We are in some ways reaching a
new age of society where possibly like your ability to work hard
will have very, very little bearing. Not no bearing.
Like I think you will be able to move up in companies. I think
you will be able to make money. But to switch social classes,
I think social mobility in America
which is by the way the thing that made America great. The the
economic mobility, sorry, not social social class mobility. Economic
mobility is the thing that has always made America great. That
you could go to America as a nobody with no background and become
part of the ruling class, a part of the most wealthy elite in
that country. That is something no other country has ever had.
That is essentially an American ideal, an American invention
that you can go from zero to hero. That you could be an immigrant
and do it. That you could be anybody and do it. It's not a myth.
It is absolutely not a myth. There are people who go from lower
class in America to upper class in America within a generation.
It's not a myth. It does
It's incredibly difficult to do, but that that idea I think is
slowly coming to an end. I think we are going to see that that
opportunity for economic mobility is going to get worse and worse
over time.
And I don't like it. So, for Sarah Longwell, I'm talking about
Sarah Longwell and what she believes about the wealth gap and
stuff. She thinks you have to work hard. And I think probably
the idea of you being able to work hard and and have that extreme
economic mobility, that may be
gone. And if that's gone, like I wonder how her opinion changes.
Nepotism is bigger now than ever. It it Dude, I'm saying that
it's possible.
I think it's slowly going to start going going from bottom 10%
to top 10%? Yes, top not even top 10%. Top 0.1%.
That you can go from outside the top 0.1% to into the top 0.1%
and that is something that doesn't present itself basically at
all in Europe, basically at all in China, basically at all in
the middle of nowhere. Nowhere is like that except for Western
liberal democracies, specifically America more than anywhere
else. You can do it in Canada. It's mostly the economic might
is just not really here. But in America more than anywhere else
this is still a thing that exists. And I'm very scared that it's
going to stop existing pretty soon.
back for the corporate centrist diet mega hacks. You're too cozy
with the right. You're too cozy with power. You're too cozy with
big money. And like now is our moment. It is the Democratic Tea
Party moment. And so uh that's what we're about to get. We're
about to see what it's like when the left actually has control.
And all I'll say is the last time the left flank actually had
was during FDR's reign. And what happened then? Well, at his
peak he had 80% of the house and 80% of the Senate. And he won
four
[__] presidential elections cuz Americans got a little
taste of something called social democracy and they creamed themselves
and they said, "Oh my god. Let's only have this forever and ever
and ever." Right? So, the same thing would happen today. If you
have somebody who's an actual social Democrat who delivers on
their promises for the American people, if they end the wars
and spend that money here at home, um it would be Americans would
breathe a huge sigh of relief and we'd finally get on the path
of fixing this country. Okay. So, um
massive W for Hasan, massive W for the left. Uh shout out to
Ezra Klein for actually being reasonable. There's parts here
and there in the article that I disagree with, but overall it
was very fair, very reasonable, very level-headed and he's telling
the truth. And he realized, "Look, I can't write an article saying
Charlie Kirk did politics the right way because he talked to
people and then also go after Hasan." Like yeah, every Democrat
in the country said, "Oh, where's the liberal Joe Rogan?" Then
here's a liberal Joe Rogan and they go, "No, not like that."
WELL, EZRA NO, NOT LIKE THAT. NO. NO, NOT LIKE THAT. NO.
I don't think Hasan's the liberal Joe Rogan. I actually think
Ezra Klein's point about this and I don't know if Kyle read the
article or just followed the Twitter thread. I thought Ezra Klein's
point about this was pretty good. Is that the liberal Joe Rogan?
There is no there's no politically centered Joe Rogan.
Joe Rogan is just Joe Rogan and he is mostly floating around
outside of a uh a a staunch like foundationally built political
base. He he sort of floats around in terms of the political landscape,
right?
So, it's like that's just it's just Joe Rogan. And Joe Rogan
was popular because he got famous early on and he was good at
just talking to people and making them feel cool and that led
to a lot of cool people coming on his podcast and eventually
it became like, "Hey, I'm the cool guy who talks to cool people
and we're we're just like you know, early mover advantage and
he just built something up that was massive, okay? Kyle calls
him a vibe monger. Well, a little bit, yeah. So, the idea that
there's a liberal Joe Rogan and people always say this about
Joe, he's the liberal Joe Rogan. But Joe was never like dead
set in anything and I think he could still come back to like
the left broadly as well. I do think that's possible. In fact,
I think it's likely after the Trump stuff, especially after Iran,
especially after what Israel is doing. Okay, that is getting
tied hard to the Republican
so anyway, I I just think you're not going to get Hasan's not
going to be the liberal Joe Rogan. Nobody's going to be the liberal
Joe Rogan who is super invested in politics because by their
nature of being super invested in politics, they are going to
essentially otherwise like 40 to 30 to 40% of the population
of America. That prevents you from ever being the liberal Joe
Rogan. There is no such thing as a liberal Joe Okay? So, we keep
going. Klein realizes that's absurd, that's ridiculous. No, this
guy is going to be in the tent and you're going to have to deal
with that even if you don't like that. Okay? So, um shout out
to Ezra for that and shout out to the Pod Save guys who never
wavered in their support of Hasan. They have some disagreements
with him, but they have those conversations on air and it's very
clear that they're working on similar political project. And
the fact of the matter is what's happening to Democrats in this
country is the exact same thing that happened to Jennifer Welch
of I've Had It podcast. She'll be the first one to tell you that
like yeah, there was a time where I loved Hillary and I hated
Bernie. And then here I here we are years later and I realized
I was wrong. I realized Bernie was the one who was actually going
to fight Trump and fight MAGA and actually deliver on promises
for the American people and for the working class. And um that's
happening to Democrats and liberals all across this country.
Is that there's a synthesis happening right now between liberals
and leftists. Where they're saying to us, "Hey, you guys were
right about you know about X, Y, and Z, about all these different
policy things, about how to fight MAGA." And on the flip side
of that, "Look, we've us leftists have taken some genuine points
from these liberals. I think the liberals were 100% correct to
be the first ones to have Trump Derangement Syndrome. Trump Derangement
Syndrome is just factually correct. It's just the right reaction
to a man who's a fascist imperialist terrorist, right?" I love
that that's what he's giving them. Yeah, that that whole thing
the Trump Yeah, you guys were on the money with that one. And
so very funny. We've taken some of their stuff, too. And I'm
willing to give them credit. You know, I've said before like
break out the liberal apology forms for a lot of the [__]
that, you know, I was originally skeptical of. No, he's the most
corrupt man to ever grace that White House ever. His populism
was completely and utterly fake. Um it the most hyperbolic, hair
on fire, liberal who went after Trump, biggest resistance types,
not only were they right, they were more right than even they
realized. Okay? So, the synthesis of liberals and leftists is
happening and it's going to continue. But, the ones who are going
to be left in the dustbin of history are the diet MAGA Democrats.
They are the corporate Democrats. They are the Israel lobby Democrats.
There's There's no coming back for them. And I think uh this
weekend proved that more than anything else ever has. Hey, y'all,
do me a favor and like and subscribe. It helps out big time in
the algo. It is really funny to me that I think I think Kyle
is doing a very similar thing.
And I'm not I'm not sure how wrong it I'm really not. But, Kyle's
doing a very, very similar thing to what, you know, the third
way types are doing, just from a leftist perspective, saying,
"Yeah, uh these people, they actually should be shunned. Like,
if you're one of the people who is pushing consistently If you
ever once said a negative thing about Lina Khan, out. Get the
[__] out of here, okay? If you ever
Well, actually, maybe it's a little further. If you've If you've
like continued to support Israel, you're you're a Fetterman type.
Also out of the coalition, all right? And I I do wonder if he's
correct about wanting to degrade his opponents before they continue
on at all.